c'est un plus que vous n'êtes même pas
chrétien alors ah bon mais le Noël c'est
une invention religieuse ou c'est pas
une inventtion oui non monsieur c'est
religieux mais alors dans les les rois
mages il y avait Melor Gaspar et
Balthazar il y avait bien c'était des
chrétiens d'abord c'était des chrétiens
le noir
aussi bonjour
bonjour oh par ici
madame
regardez le Père Noël noir et je suis
rentré dans la dame en vous regardant
stupéfaction des fois il y a des gens
qui disent que je tombe dans le charbon
ouais c'est moi qui c'est vous qui dites
ça hein ça fait rien mon gars c'est
c'est pas c'est pas très grave mais pour
pourquoi pour vous dans dans l'esprit le
Père Noël il est il est comment
pour moi quand c'est moi je suis tout
blanc quand c'est toi c'est tout noir
voilà puis si c'est un jaune il tout
jaune pour vous pourquoi il y a pas de
Noël chez vous parce que chez moi je
suis dans mon pays on est blanc oui
monsieur je suis très honoré d'être
français et je regrette de voir la
France comme elle est à l'heure actuelle
j'ai hon j'aimerais bien savoir pour
j'ai honte c'est ça que je vrais savoir
je vous dis parce qu'on est trop mélangé
monsieur ronter à l'heure actuelle la
France elle appartient à des gens qui
viennent ici que pour notre pogon et
j'en ai marre ça a rien à voir avec Noël
ça quelque chose à voir avec
Noël c'est un plus que vous n'êtes même
pas chrétien alors ah bon mais le Noël
c'est une invention religieuse ou c'est
pas une avant oui non monsieur c'est
religieux mais alors dans les les rois
mages il y avait melthor Gaspar et
Balthazar il y avait bien c'était des
chrétiens d'abord c'était des chrétiens
le noir aussi c'est pas des musulmans
c'est quoi Noël Noël à Paris pour vous
vous êtes d'où moi je suis de la martiné
queou Noël à Paris par rapport à Noël à
la Martinique c'est pas du tout la même
chose mais par exemple Noël au pays
c'est c'est je préfère vous préférez
ouais parce que on s'amuse tous dans le
village même on s'amuse pas en famille
savez il y a des gens vrai vrai y a des
G on s'amuse en village carrément a ici
c'est chacun pour so y a des gens dis il
y a des gens qui disent je viens
discuter avec eux puis qui disent oui
oui nous on est on est français
retournez donc faire Noël dans votre
pays mais moi je suis français personne
me dira pas que je suis pas Français
Noël noir ça n'existait pas avant ah non
moi de mon temps céit un père Noël blanc
mais et en Chine d'après vous comment
ils sont les Père Noël ah ben je sais
pas j'ai jamais été en Chine quand vous
voyez un père Noël comme moi qui qui
vous dit bonjour qui sourit qui est noir
vous dites ah ben ça a changé il éir les
Père Noël c'est un faux Père Noël faux
Père Noël oui mais c'est ça c'est ça que
j'ai du mal à saisir le vrai père no et
le petit Jésus il était blanc il était
noir il était comment d'après vous il
était blancid il y a des évidences comme
ça bonne journée madame allez au revoir
alors Monsieur un petit
lapin et pourquoi je suis pas le vrai
Père Noël tuas la peau je sais pas
comment dire là c'est pas bien attends
mais pourquoi qu'est-ce qu'on t'a dit
que le Père Noël il il a pas la peau
noire c'est ça parce qu' change de
couleur il change de couleur chaque
année le fait qu'il soit noir ça ça
ajoute à la confusion parce que le gosse
se dit tiens le le dernier que j'ai vu
éit blanc je viens d'en voir un jaune là
j'en voie un noir il y a plusieurs Père
Noël donc il y a pas un père Noël la
notion tu ne dramatises pas parce que je
dramatise pas du tout
s'en fout vous croyez qu'il s'en foutent
complet
regarde de
couleur comment ils étaient les autres
années madame le Père Noël
ta il y avait de tout mais enfin cétait
ils étaient blancs pour la petite
certainement c'est changé d'après vous
c'est pour la petite que ça change ou
pour oh pour moi non ça au contraire ça
me change pas du tout c'est le Père Noël
ah bon c'est le Père Noël parce que elle
avait pas l'air de remarquer que j'avais
changé ah Bonou mais c'est moi qui lui
dit ah oui oui mais mais c'est il faut
lui dire parce que des fois ça peut
changer c'est c'est cette année B c'est
le temp Noël il est coloré il est beau
il a c'est ça il faut vous dire ça à la
petite bon ben je vais leur dire mais
oui bien sûr mais c'est vrai parce que
un enfant encore elle elle se rend pas
compte mais les autres enfant bah cette
année le Père Noël il est il est plus
foncé il est c'est pas le même et
comment tu l'imagines toi le Père Noël
avec une grande barre blanche oui avec
un grand chapeau oui il est comme vous
il y a rien qui vous choque chez lui
nonir c'est ça ouais non ça me choque
pas du tout ça me choque pasendez c'est
pas normal non pourquoi je sais pas vous
en avez beaucoup des pèr Noël noir
pourquoi pas j'eni jamais vu moi Père
Noël nous avons accompagné notre Père
Noël devant l'église Saint-Nicolas du
char à Paris nous ne sommes pas restés
bien
longtemps ça vous choque quand vous
voyez un père
Noël devant
Saint-Nicolas parce que là il y a aucune
s'il vous plaît vous partez s'il vous
plaît vous êtestil pourquoi
Monsieur alors là je préfère vous dire
tout de suite que je ne partirai pas je
préfère vous le dire courtoisement
gentiment je ne partirai pasisement
sinon on va faire partir moins
courtoisement nous Enie un provocate sur
le parv
sans arrêt nous faire chier
hein arrêtez de nous faire chier sans
arrêt il y a des gens pour qui un père
Noël noir ne peut-être qu'un provocateur
et cette idée leur fait perdre toute
retenue don la cassette et c'est un des
rois était noir si si je ne me trompe et
qui vous dit que la Vierge Marie était
blanche c'est pas il y a des gens qui
sont bien Bran dans ces paysl vous
attendez à ce que les gens disent qu'ils
sont étonnés par vous êtes bonzé c'est
ça oh il y en a fa Noël ça vient du
France c'est pas vraiment bonzé y en a
certains qui disent que je suis noir
tout simplement il y en a qui une
certaine pudeur et qui disent que ça les
gêne oui ça les gêne vraiment vous cux
mais vous vous avez pas dit que j'étais
noir vous avez dit j'étais bronzé si dès
qu'on est sorti on a dit viens voir il
est Marant il est tout noir ah c'est ça
que vous voulez
dire ça vous paraî normal
c'està dire que dans le temps en
principe moi pour moi quand j'étais
enfant il y avait que un père Noël un
seul maintenant on voit des Père Noël
partout alors je sais pas ce que les
enfants eux pentent ça vousz vouu
comprenez Mo personnellement je voyais
que un PER Noël dans le monde entier moi
pour moi il quel couleur blanc et nous
sommes tous pareils nous sommes des
enfants de la vie et je crois que quand
le soleil se lève c'est la pour tout le
monde
Jean-Michel martial bonsoir vous vous
êtes débarrassé de votre habit de Père
Noël sincèrement est-ce que vous vous
attendiez à ce type de réaction à ce
type de réaction non quand même c'estàd
parce que j'imaginais pas que j'aurais
été nourri de cette manière par les uns
et par les autres à savoir que les
enfants donnent ils prennent mais ils
donnent énormément ils donnent leur
innocence il donnent leur chaleur il
donnent oh le papa Noël il donne la joie
et pour eux il importe peu que le Père
Noël soit blanc noir jaune bleu qu'il
soit grand qu'il soit petit pour ça
représente quelque chose qu'ils aiment
bien parce que entouré c'est magique
dans leur famille oui ils ontit leurs
famille font que le Père Noël est
quelque chose de magique alors et les
adultes ils m'ont donné j'ai reçu les
adultes donnent différemment ils disent
non le Père Noël c'est pas pour moi
c'est pour l'enfant mais à ce moment-là
précisément ils sont exactement l'enfant
qu'ils étaient avant et l'enfant qu'ils
ont encore chez eux ils ont la même
vibration la même lumière la même
chaleur Michel vous avez été victime
d'agression et d'agression physique au
cours de ce reportage les techniciens et
moi-même avons été victimes on a été
surpris on a été déçu parce qu'on
pensait que les gens avaient un peu plus
de jugeot tout simplement un peu plus de
tolérance qu'ils étaient un peu plus
responsables de leur foi responsable de
leurs idées responsable d'eux-mêm je
trouve que c'est dommage pour eux pour
les individus qu'ils sont et que c'est
peut-être grave pour la société dans
laquelle nous vivons et que nous
construisons alors quand ça vous arrive
dans la vie quotidienne lorsque vous
êtes victime d'une agression physique ou
verbale hein qu'est-ce que vous
faites je souffre d'abord je reçois
ensuite j'essaie de réagir alors des
fois maladroitement je ris jaune c'est
un noir qui rit jaune et qui fait ce
qu'il peut avec et si j'en ai la force
j'essaie d'établir le dialogue parce que
le dialogue permet d'aller plus loin et
ça marche ça dépend je fais ce que je
peux à savoir que j'ouvre la porte et ce
sont les autres qui reçoivent qui ont la
clé à savoir ils reçoivent ou ils ne
reçoivent pas mais je suis main ouverte
et de toute façon je continue ma route
parce que l'histoire avance et je suis
dans l'histoire vous seriez prêt à
recommencer ce ce type d'expérience en
sortant d'ici je remets ma hte et mon
manteau
[Musique]
rouge